so hat er sagen
aus heutiger sicht heute dass ich eher
ein mini-break
[Musik]
ja
heute entscheidet sich nicht nur das
schicksal der fdp in niedersachsen
sondern auch das von philipp rösler ist
partei kein wunder und philipp geschickt
hat machst du hier siehst doch eindeutig
irgendwie alle welt geschickt den besten
mann hin
[Musik]
was sind die vorteile von philipp rösler
ist obwohl doch nicht so aussieht ein
niedersachse durch und durch das jeder
vermutet schlagfertiger den gästen sind
gar nicht antworten
ihr habt noch spaß ich bin der richtige
reporter haben sind heute zwei tage
rainer brüderle sagen würde zu viel
[Musik]
wenn sie jetzt eine frau kennenlernen
was sagen sie der was sie beruflich
machen
wir sagen ja nicht fdp politiker oder
der stimmen gekommen
wer hat mehr humor die fdp oder die
wähler auf jeden fall die fdp ja dann
mach doch eine frage deine blöde fragen
philipp rösler ist nicht volkstümlich
volkstümlicher kommt bei den leuten
nicht an das ist also seine rhetorik
kommt bei den leuten nicht an weil es
ist halt die art wie er spricht das
überzeugt sind nicht aber ich finde sie
sind fdp natürlich lieber bescheiden
optimistisch ist und müssen dass meine
kamera
wir sind im kann sein dass hier noch
leer ja nicht die fdp niedersachsen
aus heutiger sicht viele philipp rösler
hat den satz nach 50 und 100
ich weiß dass man aus heutiger sicht
erst mal kann ich sagen dass christian
linder
mannschaft ich sagen ich weiß alles in
die welt müsste man eigentlich mal die
ehrenmitgliedschaft in der fdp
weil der hat so eine ehrung für uns
gemacht sie hat nämlich den leuten die
gelegenheit gegeben zu sehen dass die
fdp politiker ganz sympathische leute
sind ja tolle videos steht einmal
erklären
das ist mit ihnen auf einer fdp
wahlparty war
darüber muss sich nicht schämen das
wurde einfach können stolz sein weil
werden erfasst wird das würde heute
sagen dass später wir müssen über eine
zahl stellt eine frage herr werden muss
für die heute stehen sie heute
vielleicht einmal innsbruck
die frage man tue alles was ich von
beiden auf und was verboten 180 fotos
von opfern und die heißt gut und damit
und damit gebe ich habe super wenn sie
den brauch nach köln
damit gehen zurück das waren die heute
show classics mit lutz van der horst ich
bin losfahren draußen und nächsten
freitag abend unbedingt wieder zdf
einschalten